さて、
今、私たちは再びライブになっているので、
このリンクもリツイートし
ます。
チャンネルをアップしてください。
コンテンツライブに行くと、本当に悲しいです。コンテンツライブに行くと
、別のビデオのように見える
ので、
今は大丈夫
です。
私たちが実際にやったジョークビデオをもっと長くやった
ので、私たちが
やった
ばかりのビデオは、スクリプト化されたビデオでした。
彼がやって来
て私のライブストリームを引き継ぐのが好きなスクリプトライブストリームのようにやるのはちょっとしたことですが、
多くの人が
実際にいくつかの質問を
したいと思ったので
、適切なええとのようにフォローアップするのが最善だと思いました
qa
多分私は10分か15分わからない
のでこれは
私のチャンネルに残ります ええと、
やまだんさんも少し性格が違うかもしれませんが、
私は
このビデオのためにもう少しリラックスしてい
ます。東京オリンピックは
失敗です。私はオリンピックについて少し心配
しています。
日本を不況に陥らせたいあなたはよく心配しています
か
私は知りません私は日本が人口減少のために
すでに一種の
不可避の不況にあると思います
そして確かに
コロナは
東京オリンピックでそれをまったく助けていません
でもそれは、日本がそれを修正してバックフリップをするためにできることは本当に何もない
と思いますええと、
もうバックフリップをすることはでき
ません。
ええと
[音楽]
はゴミの味に出てくる予定ですええと、
私はただ固執すると
言うでしょう、そしてあなたはいつか
あなたがスペインのヤバタンまたはドーゲンを話しますか私
はスペイン語を話しません私は高校で少し勉強しました
いいえ、私はスペイン語
を話しません。 記念碑
的ですが、あなたは英語の日本語とノルウェー語を話しますが、
それ以外は何でもありません。
私はモノマネーが得意です。大丈夫だ
と思います。ほとんどのアクセントができます。
あなたが
投稿した最初のビデオの1つを覚えておいてください。
私が思うに
、あなたが持っていたアクセントは、
日本語のアクセントを話すフランス語の人
のようなものでした。今では、フランス語の
要素が
消えたようです。 少し
はフランス語で始まりました
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
アバタンそれはもうフランス人のようではない
そうそうそうそうそれはそれ自身のもののように今それは
それ自身のキャラクターの
ようになって
いる
コースと
私はあなたの後ろに落ちたように感じますみんな
は勉強のヒントを持っています
ええと私は知りません私は最も
重要なことの1つは
モチベーションだと思います 自分が使っ
ている教科書のように勉強するのが好きなの
ですが
、何もしないよりも、日本の映画やアニメのよう
に
使うほうがいいと思います。 教科書ですが、
飽きてきて、やりたくないみたいです
iiアニメアニメに興味があったの
は、何もないよりはましな
ので、モチベーションはとても
重要なことです。
エンゲージメントを維持し、モチベーションを維持
して、本当に好きな良い映画のように見つけ
て、それを繰り返し見て
ください。これは、あなたのフーディーをどこからでも確実に得ることができます。
あなたはあなたのキックを
東京で
手
に入れます 原宿と渋谷の間の猫通りに店を構える
私はそれをお勧めしますそして
興味のある人
には彼は彼の新しい商品を立ち上げましたそして私は
ちょっとそれを手に入れました 人々は
私のツイッタードーガンに行くことができますそしてあなたは私の
友達
かもしれません多分私はあなたの
あなたの商品リンクを
私のツイッターで本当に素早く共有する
でしょう この
限定版のyabathonグッズ
を手に入れ
ましょう。私は大丈夫です。どこにいるのか見てみましょう。私はすでにあなたを通り過ぎて
い
ます。 私が
数ヶ月見てきたビデオ、そして私は
あなたのスキットを本当に楽しんでいます
ありがとうございます私はそれを感謝しますええと、
別のスーパーチャット
がありました
ファンだけをやめなければならなかった 残念ながら、
これは興味深いかもしれません。私たち
は両方ともこれに答えることができます。
私のアドバイスを教えた後、日本に滞在したい英語の外国人のためのアドバイスはあります
か？
英語を教えるのに飽きたら、頼りになる
ことがある
ので、日本で英語を教えたことはありますか？
8か月間大丈夫だったかもしれませ
んが、コメディーを始め
ました。 その時
私は実際に
働いていた
ので
私はacaiwaと
huiglenで働いていました
離陸を開始した
iiは幸運にもnhkに迎えられ
、日本に滞在することができました。基本的
には、休暇
ビザを取得し
ていたので、そのビザの最後に、基本的な
唯一の選択肢
でした。 大丈夫だから私はnhkによって救われました
面白いほとんどの人
彼らはhkでネガティブな話しか持ってい
ません
私は
東京に住んでいないのでちょっと大変です
が、比較的近い将来に東京に行く
予定なので、比較的近い将来には行け
ないかもしれませんが
、コメディーの後に
行く可能性があります。 東京での生活について教えてください。
アジアでの生活についてもっと教えてください。
私の家の近くの大学について
は、今はしません。それ
は、実際にapuについてのビデオを作成するからです。
比較的近い将来
、
かなり広範になるので、誰か
が見たいと思ったら、そのビデオからそれについてもっと学ぶことができます
[笑い]
ええ、それは面白いですええ
ええ完全に別の人私はええええと思います
がそれはキャラクターですええと
コメディだから
そうそうね uysは実際
に私の側面を見ることができてとても幸運です
ええそれはええと私は
あなたがオンラインで投稿したものを見たことがないと思います
ビデオの最後に英語を話し
ましたええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
あなたのチャンネルで突然完全に異なるスタイル
を知っているあなたは他の人のチャンネルで私のチャンネルから人々が知っていることを知ってい
ますええ
この通常の声で
ええええそれは私の通常の通常の性格です
ええと、ヤバタンの声
は英語で本当に違うように聞こえ
ます。
どうやってあなたたちはどうやって会ったのですか。また、
ヤバタンさんは英語でキャラクターの音をどうやって鳴らします
か。 彼がオンラインで投稿したビデオ
は本当に面白いと思い
ました。日本には外国人のようにyoutubeでコメディーをする人が
あまりいないので、彼が投稿したビデオを見たとき、
これは別の人だと思いました。 私のように
、外国人として日本で日本でコメディーをやってい
ますええと、私たちが会えることを願ってつながりを作りましょう、
そしてあなたは
一緒にいくつかの楽しいビデオを作ることを知ってい
ます 私たち二人とも
連絡を取り、それ以来連絡を取り合っている
ので、残りは歴史
です。あなたが料理できる最高の料理
は何ですか。新しい料理を採用しました。まったく料理できません。料理でき
ます。
ええと
、3、4か月前
はかなり厳格なビーガンでしたが、今
は
一種のビーガンです。実は
、就学前のことを何と呼んでいます
か。正確なことは思い出せません。
用語ですが、
たまに魚を食べているようです
が、他に好きなものはありませ
ん とにかく肉や卵などの動物性食品
[音楽
]別府ではなく九州周辺で好きな温泉
黒川温泉
黒川温泉と思います有名な名前だと思いますが、
実際はそうは思いません 行っ
たことはありますが、別府ではない
ので有名なので
、日本でハラール食品
を見つけるのは難しいので
、他のほとんどの国よりも日本で見つけるのは難しいと
思い
ます。 国によっては
もちろんです
が、別府のように
ハラールメニュー
があるところ
もあります。国際色豊かな学生がたくさん
いるので、色んなところから来ている
ので、真面目そうに見えます。 どちらも
腕を
組んで
いるのが好きです[音楽][笑い]そうですね、いい質問です[音楽]あなたがツイッターで彼女をフォローしているので、あなたは私がたくさんやっているのが好きだと知っています。
ええ、私は大好きですが
彼女もとてもクレイジーな才能
を
持っています。私自身はシーナリンゴのファンですが、私は完全に
理解していて、宇多田ヒカルも大好き
です。彼女のアルバムは
ディープリバーだと思います。
ええと、それは手紙と呼ばれていると思います
ええと、それは本当に有名な曲ですそれ
は王国の心の
歌のようなものですそのアルバムのすべての曲の
ようなアルバムは信じられないほどですそのアルバムは
間違いなく傑作
です
最近、日本のすべての地震で大丈夫
でしたか？2
日前の東京のような地震があったと思いますが、
そこにいたのか、それとも大丈夫でしたか？
私が住んで
いるbeppuの大きなものはありますが、東京はどうでした
か？1、2か月前に別の大きな
もの
がありました。  a 長いものなので
、
数秒
は少し揺れているのを知っているようなものですが、
今回は長い間続いているようなもので
、本当に怖くなり始めまし
た。 少し怖いですええ
、4年前と同じくらいの大きさだったと思い
ますえ
えと、4年前
に日本にいたかどうかわからない大きなものがありました
が、私は この辺りではなかったの
ですが、実は
とても強かったので
、妻が働いていたホテルの
ように、それ自体は完全には崩壊しませんでした
が、物理的に破壊しなければならないほど崩壊しなければなりませんでし
た。 それ
はもはや安全ではなく
、彼らはそれを最初から作り直さなければならなかったので
、それが基本的に私の妻
があなたがそこで働くことを知っているのを止めなければならなかったので
それが起こったときそれは怖かったです
私のスタイルが欲しい
ちょっと私のえ
えと、私生活をプライベートに保つために、私は
性格を壊してこのようなことをするのは気になりません
が、特に彼らがいるので、
私の子供と妻を基本的
にチャンネルから遠ざけたい
です すぐに学校を始めるので、
誰かが尋ねているので、あなたは
結婚し
ていますか私に尋ねますええいいえ私は結婚し
ていませんいいえ私はまだまだです
それはあなたたちがどのように会ったかでした
そのええと、英語でのトランプの音をありがとう
それについてええ、
彼は日本人に固執するだろうと思います
ええ
、私たちが過去に行ったビデオの1行の
ように、ええと
、あなたはどのようにやってい
ますか？
ええ、vチューバーの代わりに今夜男の子のためにシンピングして
くれてありがとう
私たちは今までにドーガを手に入れます n hentai
channel
ええと
、近い将来ではないかもしれません
が、
YouTubeは私がその方向に進むためにかなり大きなヒットをとらなければならないかもしれません
が、ええと、それは完全にテーブルから外れていません。
最初に
私のビデオがオーストラリアでバイラルになりました私は日本人を話す
イギリス人の男のパロディーを作りまし
たマクドナルドに行き
ますああ本当に私は
大丈夫コニチワ
ミナサンああミネソンミッテマルコドナルドを見たことがないと思います
オーストラリアのファンのようにたくさんの
人を集めていますが、私の目標は常に
日本人のようなものだったので、私は多くの
キャラクターを持っていました。私はフランス人のキャラクターを
イギリス人のキャラクターにしました。
それで私は
ミドルタウンの
イルミネーションに行きました。
そのビデオええと、私
は
インスタグラムとフェイスブックにアップロードし、誰かが
それをツイッターに再投稿しました
ええ誰かがビデオを盗んでツイッターに置いたの
でええ日本人の人
そしてそれから 2日後、私のインスタグラム
はええのような日本人に夢中になり始めました
、そしてそのビデオは日本のツイッターで非常にバイラルに
なりましたそして私はそれが私のチャンスだと思い
ましたええええとクリスマスのためにノルウェーに
戻って日本に戻って
たくさんのビデオを作りましたそしてそれらのほとんどは
ええ、日本でツイッターでバイラルになりましたええええええええそれからそれは9つのギャグと
すべてのもののよう
でした
ああ、私は実際に日本のインターネットのようにたくさんのことをやったことがあり
ます。
そうそう日本のテレビや日本の
ウェブそうそうそうそう
そうそう私のキャリアはそうそう始めたと思います
そして私はまだ
そうそうそうしています 私は誰か
がそれの9つのギャグを言ったのを覚えていますええ
私は4回のように9人の男にいたと思います
スーパーチャットumのludacrisに感謝しますそして私たちは新しいものを手に
入れました ハに行く
他のビデオで
彼がこれをノックダウンした場所を少し忘れた
ので、このライトは
実際にはここの中にはありません
が、ええと、このライトは実際に
は日本の永平寺からのものです。
僧侶が作っ
て、妻の亡き祖母が
実際にそのお寺に行って、
何年も前にこれを直接購入し
ました。妻のジカに行ったとき、彼らの家で一度見ました。
これを小道具として使ってみ
てください。私が使っているのと同じキャラクターで、そうそう、
まったく元気
でした。質問は日本の外国語なので、日本語で話すべきかどうかわかりません。
[音楽]
[ 音楽]
現在視聴している703人の人は
かなりいいです
それは私にとってはかなり
良いです
ええあなたのレコードは何
ですか ええと、やればやる
ほど、いわば目新しさの要素
が薄れて
きて、最近かなりの数のライブ
ストリームを
やったので、いつもより少ない人だと思います。
以前に何かを見たことがある
か、多分よく
あなたが今
いることを知らない人が多いと思います
たぶん私はインスタグラムをライブでやります大丈夫
後で大丈夫
トラッシュテイストゲストが勝ち
ます
私は
かなりすぐになりますええと、
基本的に私はちょうど私の女の子
が2週間以内に学校を始めるのを待っ
ています
そしてまた
私は好きになりたくないのでコロナが東京で少し落ち着くのを待っています
この大規模なスパイクの真っ只中にあり
ますが、かなり近い将来にそう
です。
私を招待してくれたすべてのゴミ味の人たちにあなたは私
がいることを楽しみにしています私
はそれらすべての人たちを愛しています
あなたは日本のコメディを楽しんでいます
か 大きな
誤解は、
日本のコメディはただのスラップスティックコメディ
であり、スラップスティックコメディはたくさんあるが、スラップスティック
コメディではない日本のコメディがたくさんある
ということです。 日本のスタンドアップコメディと比較し
て、西部では自己非難のユーモアが多く
、アメリカのスタンドアップコメディのようなスラップスティックのユーモアは少ないと思います
が、
それはかなり
大きな一般化だと思います それについての
考え、
または私が日本のコメディについて好きなの
は、
それが私の意見ではとても創造的であるという点で非常にユニークであるという
ことです。
それは
シモネッタのようなもの
で、そのようなジョークを作るのは簡単なようです
が、日本で
は少なくとも、まだ作成されていない特別なものを見つけるために彼らが深く掘り下げているような気がし
ます
繰り返しになり
ますが、表面レベルのように見ているだけなら、私がやった
ような一般化のようなものを作るのは簡単
ですが、同時に
日本のコメディにも非常に深くて本当に創造的なええとビットがたくさんある
ので、私は完全に同意します サムの
歌
のように私はサムが大好きです彼は天才のようだと思い
ます それは
あなたがそれ
を使うことができる方法の1つです
が、それはあなたがそれを使うことができる方法の1つですが、それはあなたが
ワンガを完全に使う方法を決して理解し
ないということですそれは状況の現実です r
多くの状況
ですが、実際には同じ
テキスト
のように、粒子を
省略して、5人の異なる日本人のように見せて、
ワウとガをどこに
置くべきかを言うことができます。
場所は
、100
パーセント正しいか100間違っているかの問題では
ないので、使用方法が異なるため、
正しい答えが常に1つあるとは限りません。その
ため、
非ネイティブスピーカーが完全に把握することは非常に困難です。
それを使って、いつ使うかを完全に理解してください。それぞれの状況で、私
は決して理解できないでしょう。
[音楽]
よくわかりません。2つのスーパーチャットをありがとうございます。
何年もあなたを
フォローしているガイジンタレントについて、
タネカミやイケノエラの
ようにどう思いますか
？ ええと、私は
彼を個人的には知りませんが、彼
は本当に素晴らしい
仕事をたくさん
していると思います。
一般的なコメディですが、彼はまた
、子供のショーのようにやったこともあります
ええ
、もちろん、申し訳ありませんが、より良い名前ですええ
、彼は
素晴らしい仕事をしています彼はそれを殺しています私は
他の人を
知りません 多分あなたは
私がテレビをやったことがない、または
あなたが
テレビをやったよう
なことについてもっと話すことが
できる
かもしれません 彼がそうでないかどうかはわかり
ませんが、それは
間違いなく素晴らしいです。なぜなら、その
ような
才能のほとんど
は、通常、半分の日本人のことを知っている
からです。彼が100人の
日本人ではない場合、100％の人として突破するのは本当に難しいので、それは素晴らしいです。
業界
とそれがあなたがmがないことを知っている理由です
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ私はそれがジミーショーだという意味です
ええと、私の意見ではフリーランスに行くほうがいいです
ええ
、フリーランサーとしてテレビに乗るのは難しいですが、
ええと、彼はうまくやっているようだと思います。
彼は正しい仕事を続けるためにここ
にいます
最近YouTubeにやってきたの
は、オリエンタルの
中田敦彦さんが大好き
な人のようです。彼のYouTubeチャンネルは本当に好きです。彼
は、人々に型にとどまらないように勧めるような最先端のことを言っています。
それで
伝統的なモードの型で話すと、
YouTubeやこれらのさまざまなプラットフォームの
ようなものをユニークな方法
で利用することを知っています。
あなたは
私がこれをやりたいようですが、あなたの
夢のマシンはあなたがこれを行うことはできないと言っていますあなたはこれ
をしなけれ
ばなりません
フリーランサーとしては好きなことをすることができ
ますが、日本のジムショーは基本的にテレビで見る必要があるので、テレビに乗るのは難しい
です
が、それは不可能ではありません。
最も重要なことは
、プロデューサー
やカメラの後ろにいる人々と友達になることです
ええ、カメラの前では
ありませんえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
英語を教えたり、第二言語を教えたりするクラスがあれば、他の言語のより良い教師になる
ことをお勧めするクラスはありますか？言語
学は良いクラスになるかもしれません
あなたが知っている音声学あなたがピッチアクセントを知っている
ようなものやこれらの本が
話しているよう
なもののよう
に私が英語の先生だったときに私が以前の学生の多くに教えるのを助けたさまざまな小さな詳細のようなもののように私は
単に言うのではなく実際に物事を正しく説明することができました
ネイティブのアクセントが付いて
いるので、あなたの言語が
この正確な位置にある
必要はないように言うことができます。それは
、あなたのライブストリームの大ファンでミスターイエローを見て本当に
驚いたことです。 私たちを
笑わせてくれてありがとうポーランドからこんにちはを見てくれて
ありがとう日本を作ってくれてありがとう日本を作って
くれてありがとう 楽しい私は
あなたの両方の大ファンです彼はあなたが何を
考えていると思いますかあなたは日本のことについて最も難しい部分だと思います
つまり、漢字などは他にもたくさんあり
ますが、漢字は
携帯電話などを使って実際に回避できますが
、
何や神のように、
1つまたは 他の人はそれを
認めることができますが、それを
省略することで、正しいものが
何であるかわからないので、あなたがそれを言って回避しようとしていることに人々が
気付くようなものです
日本語の専門家がいないので
、あなたが現在取り組んでいることを先生に任せます。
実際、私は現在日本語を勉強し
ていないので、
もっとよく勉強する必要があり
ますが、同時に
あなたは
私は日本語を教えているので、それは一種の必需品です。
確か
に、ある程度
のレベルに達し
たら、特に
日本に住んで
いる場合は、
混乱したり、
毎日
元気に行けたら
、勉強の必要性は
やがて消えていく
ような日常のトラブルは、自分の目標
次第です。
aiのようにやっている
と、会社のライブストリームや
、スクリプト全体を書き直さなければならないことは何でもわかりません。
なぜなら、私はテネのように話すことができない
からです
。 どちら
に取り組みたいのか私はケゲル
で上手になりたい
です
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ、
それから英語のエスパノール
よく[音楽]高校で3年間勉強した
ので、
教科書を開い
て勉強しようとし
たら、少し話せるかわからないけど、
全部忘れてしまいまし
た。 ええ、それは
東京
だと思いますああええ、私はそのチャンネルを見たと思い
ますええ、コメディチャンネルは
あなたのコンテンツを愛している2人の両方に少しのサポートを示したかっただけ
です
[音楽]
漫才デュオを結成することを考えた
ことがあるええと、ヤバタンさんは私に
スタンダップコメディのようにやってもらいたいと思ってい
ます。
アクティブなオーディエンスがいないときはずっといい
ので、
私とあなたのように
、私たちが私の寝室に一人でいるときは、このようなことをしても大丈夫ですが
、私の前に千人の日本人がいる場合
は、 スクリプト化されていても、面白いことを言うことに自信がない
私はそれを完全に覚えて
います私たちは練習するつもりですええ私たちは多分それをするのを見るでしょ
う
v2のですが、私はそれがキズナだと思い
ましたええ、彼女はジョーイと一緒にビデオをやりまし
たアニメの男ええと
私は2、3年前のように言いたい他の友人の一人です
それはとても良かったですそれは
私がそれをオンにしたことを覚えているようなとても良い面白いビデオでしたそして
ああこれはコンピューターモニターの
ように話しているジョーイだったのでちょっと奇妙なようです
または10
秒でした。とても面白かったし、彼らの
相性もとても良かった
ので、今夜は本当に素晴らしいビデオでした。
彼女は明らかに本当に
面白かったです。ジョーイは
すごいです。彼は本当に
賢いです。
私たちはk
先ほどお話ししましたが、
まだかなりの量の文法に問題が
あります。多くの人がゴミの味について質問し
ているのはいつか見てみましょう。日本語か英語のどちらかを話す
ことが期待されるのは奇妙なことです。
ああいつもあなた
の母国語の代わりに
私の妻はここで子供たちと散歩に行きました
多分あなたは少しの間チャットを扱うことができます
私はそれに慣れましたえ
えと時々私
はそれに少し飽き
ますええあなたのような 自分の
母国語を忘れてしまうこともあり
ます。ノルウェー語を話すとき、言葉
が切れないので、自然に出てこないので、本当に怖いです。
ええと、
もっと話します。もっと日本人の
友達
がいます。 ええと、
それはちょっと変なことです時々私
はノルウェー語を忘れてしまう
ので、私の
メッセージ
があなたのコンテンツの両方を愛して送ったかどうかわからない私は
インタビューyにすぐにインタビューすることができるかどうか疑問に思いました ouヨガオンラインで
日本のコメディについて話すumgrantgaylord
ええと、あなたはそのumについてのメールを送信する必要があり
ますええ、それはあなたのツイッターのようにあなたのメールです
ええそれはどこにでもあるべきです
今日
はまだ見たことがないと思いますが、本当にワクワクしているので、
本当に見事だと思います。
やばたんさんは
、日本語が流暢に話せることに驚かされることがあります。
あなたのソーシャルメディアビデオとスムーズに比較します
ええもちろんいつも
ええええと私が人々に会うときあなた
は
私が私の通常の声で話すとき本当に
本当に驚いていることを知っていますええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ もう一度幸せになり、彼らは
私がこのように話すことを忘れているので、
大丈夫です
ええ、人々は幸せなアバターを好む
私は幸せですが、私はエネルギッシュな
ヤバタの
ように意味するので、ファンに会うと私はキャラクター
になります 話し続ける私は
徐々に通常に戻りますそして
通常人々
はあなたのビデオよりも道元が涼しいと言いますええ私は
カメラから離れた現実の生活でよく見えますええ
確かにええ確か
にええ
ええと、
私は知らないのですが、ほとんどの人のカコイのイメージ
や
、あなたがよく知っていることは何だと思いますか？
それはあなたが知っていることです
あなたのキャラクターそれはキャラクターなので
私は決してキャラクターを変更することはありません
あなたが知っているカコエあなたが正しいことを知っ
ています
私です
が
、彼らもあなたを好きです
ええと道元日本の
新首相は別の回転首相になるのでしょう
か私は知らないのですが
日本の地方
政治にあまり従わない
のです k 就任以来、あちこちにいる
ので、かなり近い将来に
新首相が就任することもあるかもしれ
ませ
んが、それ以上のことは何も言えません。
完全な
ガイド私はうまくいきますこれは興味深い
質問です。なぜなら、ノルウェーでは
ほとんどの人が英語を話すからです。なぜなら、
それは
シンガポールのようなものなのか、言葉が
消えていくのか
、私たちが英語の言葉を使うようなノルウェー語のようなものなのか、私にはわかりません。
もっと
本当に私たちの言語ではそうそうそうそう
ですがそれ
はあなたがノルウェー語を話している
ようなもので、ランダムな
英語の単語のようなものです
か、それとも完全に英語の文法で英語に切り替え
ますか、それともあなたは好きですか
つの組み合わせそれは組み合わせです私はそれが
よりノルウェー語であると思いますそしてそれから言葉は
あなたの中にいくつかの英語の単語を知っています
たとえばカタカナイーグルのような英語の発音は、
何かを切り替えるために
、英語の単語であるスイッチと言います。ああ、それは英語の単語です。
外来語は
日本語の発音で発音されて
おり、ある程度は
カタカナ
で
英語が教えられているので、日本語は日本語で奇妙なことかもしれません。
カタカナですが、日本語には外来語がたくさんあるので
、普通の英語の発音
に慣れていると、普通の英語の
ようにイチゴのような単語を言うのは難しいので、
普通の英語の発音のようだと思われます。
iiのように言うことは、日本語でそれを言うことさえできません。
なぜなら
、発音がええのように非常に異なって
いるからです。
ええと
、ブレーンストーミングを知っているのではなく、ブレーンストーミングのようなことを言って育ったので、私にはわかりません。
それは
英語のように複数の言語を話すことができる
ので、おそらく
あなたがちょうど
ノルウェー人と一緒に説明したようなものに少し
近づくでしょうええ、良くも悪くも、幸せな人の邪悪な双子の兄弟の前にいるヤバタンです
それともこれはもっと蜂蜜な
ので、多分これはあなたのええとホネットとあなたの
他の
キャラクターですそれを説明するのに良い方法です
ねえドーゲンとヤバタンええと私たちは
今秋東京の大学院に行くでしょう
外国人にとって
は、東京の大学院に行けばきっと
たくさんの
チャンスがあると
思います。特に日本語を話せば
、できるだけ日本語を上達させたいと思います。
大学院に行く場合
は、明らかに
1つの科目を非常に高いレベル
で始めていることを意味します。
どの科目でも
それができるほど、その可能性が高くなります。
それ
を変えることができれば、その
知識は儲かる職業のようになり
ますええと、私たちはあなたについてあまり知りませんが、私たちが知っていること
から
、私は
あなたの両方をとても尊敬していますあなたの態度
は私に何度かインスピレーションを与えまし
た
いいですねライブで、ヤバタンの
性格を
もっと頻繁に見たいと思っています。それは良いニュースです。
先に述べたように、
もちろん、それはあなたの経営者の決定のほうがいいと思いました
が、
ええと、オンラインで何かをやってみてください
。 あなた
はいつも性格ではあり
ませんええええ私は将来の計画があることを知っていますそうええ
しかしええそれはゆっくりと段階的なプロセスでなければなりません
はい多く
のええと私はあなたがええとまったく異なる聴衆を持つ多くの異なるチャンネルを持っていることを知っています
s  oi
は少しである
必要があります私は特定のことを行う方法を考えなければなりません
ええ確か
にええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 日本のマンガを読んで
ください。
最初にひらがなとカタカナから始めて、
それら
を覚え
てから、このストリームの開始に向けた動機について
少し話しましたが
、 あなたが一生懸命勉強しているので、あなたは
自分自身を燃え尽きさせてしまうので、
多分大丈夫だと思うように私は毎日
この簡単な本の1ページのように読んでみようと
思います 一日
、特に就寝前にそれを行うと、
あなたの脳は眠りにつく直前にあなたが考えたことを処理する傾向があるので、それは本当に
良いことがあります。
毎晩、寝る前に少し日本語を話し
ます。すぐにそこに着くことができるかもしれません。
私の友人の旅行ビクターのフレーム
もここにいます。
東京の写真家です。
彼の写真のいくつかは
、電車のようなホッカイドの写真のように
見たことがあるかもしれません。私は、彼が本当に才能があり、ddrも本当に得意だと思っています。
立ち寄ってくれて
ありがとうビクター最後にダブルテイクの
反応があったのは、誰かがあなたが日本語を話すのを聞いたとき、
どうやって
うまく反応したのかわからないわからない
わからない 日本語を上手に話す
ことは、beppuで日本語をかなり上手に話すとき、人々が驚かないようです。
また、私の日本語は完璧ではありません。
パネセつまり、私の日本語は
かなり上手だと思いますが、完璧
ではないので、まるであなたが知っ
ているように、政治について2時間の会話をすることができ
、人々
は私がずっとネイティブスピーカーだと思っ
ているわけではありません。 確かに
そうではありませんが、ええと、
私はコロナやものをあまり使わない傾向があり
ません。とにかく、あまり多くの新しい日本人に会うことはありません。
アメリカーノのように、
彼女が
あなたに知ってほしい人がいるので、そのような短い会話では
、そのようなことは決して起こり
ません。私は
あなたにそのようなことが起こることは
よく
わかりません。
実際に日本語が話せますええ私は毎日日本語を話しますええでも私
は東京に住んでいるので
もっと多くの人が行く場所を知ってい
ますえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ  大学時代の
ドーガンのトレーニングルーチンが何だったのか見てみましょう
彼はその古いトリックビデオでひどく破れたように見えました
またこの
ストリームは保存されますそうそうこのストリームは保存されますええ
と私はちょうどよく私はほとんどちょうど
かなりの量をしました ウェイトリフティングのようですが
、
バックフリップやフロントフリップのような実際のトリックもたくさん
好きでした。そのようなことは
あなたのコアの強さのように本当に良いので、
それをたくさん
するのは本当に良いトレーニングであり、私
は 逆立ちのようなものがたくさん
あるので、
私は本当に決まったルーチンを持っていなかったのかわかりません。
なぜなら
、私がうまくいくのに十分健康であると感じた場合、
代わりにだましてしまうことがよくあります
が、私はたくさんのタンパク質が好きで、
それが助けになりました 筋肉をつけたり
、初めて東京に引っ越したりする人への
アドバイスはどうしたいですか
[音楽]
初心者は東京に引っ越すためのアドバイスを期待しています
トク
中央から離れて、
地元の人と話をしてみてください。ただ飛び込んではいけませ
ん。ココサークルはすぐに、
別の場所に行ってみてください。
別のサークルに行って
ください。 ええと、どうやっ
て英語で言うのかわからないの
ですが、いろいろな見方をしてくださいええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
外国人全員と一緒に過ごして
、日本人と
一緒に過ごしてみてくださいええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
あっという間に疲れて
しまう東京の、東京の郊外にいるのもいいと思います。
そうすれ
ば、その呼吸する部屋に静かな
小さな
近所の落ち着いた近所を見つけて住むことができ
ます。 そこに住んで
、渋谷に行って、そこに行くエネルギーがあれば、これらすべてのクレイジーな
場所に
行きましょう。1時間ほど
かかるので、おそらく10分ほどで停止
しますが、
できるだけ多くの回答をします。 コロナが日本問題について私が最も恋しいことを始めて以来、日本の留学生がエディンバラで立ち往生し
ていると話す
とき、あなたが別の国にいるとき、あなたは日本について何が一番恋しいです
か？
そしてまた、ええ、私はそれ
が日本で一般的に非常に安全であることを知りません非常に安全
です
それは
私が知らない場所です私はノルウェーがかなり安全だと想像しますえええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ
ええ、ほとんどの国より安全だと思います
ええ、ええ、どこに行くかによります
ええええ、
日本食と言って、
安全でリラックスした気分
になります。  o
アリガトを知りたいスーパーマーケット、そうそうそうそう、日本で2年連続で過ごした後
、初めてアメリカに戻ったとき、私が地下鉄のサンドイッチに入ったのと同じよう
に、コンベニューに入るのはとても奇妙に感じたのを覚えてい
ます。 日本でいつも知っている
友達いつも
そうです
[音楽
]いつもこんな
感じですが、アメリカに戻ったときは、普通のアメリカの地下鉄のように初めて入ったような感じ
でした。 すぐ
に私に言った
ねえ、あなたは私が良い一日を過ごしていることを知っています
、そして私は
プライバシーの侵入が
プライバシーの
侵入のようでしたそれはかなり面白かったです
[音楽]
あなたも完全に
アルゼンチン
アルゼンチンに行きたいのですが
、ポッドキャストについても少し
前に
話し
ました。私が話していたのは
、レトロなgeysingの作品に
もある種の何かがあるということですが、私たちはあなたに知ってもらいました。
いくつかのfl そこに柔軟性があるので、
私たちはおそらく何かをすることができるということ
ですええ私は何でも開いています
ええそれは女の子が学校を始めるときにどれだけの
時間を持っているかが本当に重要
です
犬とヤバトンさんは、他の人を笑わせる能力を失う
ことを恐れていた時期がありましたか？
2つの
異なる質問があります。1つはコメディアン
のように自分に自信があります
か、もう1つは
日本語を話すことに
自信がありますか？ 新しい
ジョークを考えないことをあまり心配したことはありませんでした
あなたはどう
ですか サイン ある
日は間違いなく他の日よりもかなり悪いですが、それ
を修正する最も簡単な方法
は、日本の映画をオンにして、
朝中ずっとそのままにして、一緒に話す
か、あなたが知っているようにすることだと思います
積極的に聞いて
、家を出てやりたい
ことをやるときは、本当に日本人
っぽいモードに
なっているので、いわば大いに役立ちます。
日本の会社のようなストリームやもの、
それはあなたが知っている良い試験
ですええ日本のええそう
です
がそれからあなたは私がそれをするたびに
私がより良くそしてよりリラックスしているように感じ
ますええあなた
はあなたが何であるかに飛び込む必要があります
怖いのか、そういうのかわからない
けど、こういうことができるのかわからない
ええ、何があっても良くなる
もう一度、ええと、あなた
はすべて良い機会を知っていますか 日本の
フランス語を話す人のためにフランス語を話すために
翻訳を教える
など、フランス語を学びたい人や
フランス語の翻訳が必要な仕事をしたい人が必ずいるということです
が、需要は
英語市場のように、そして
私は個人的には
出現しないと信じていますが、ええと
、
機械学習のqは、
翻訳の機会がうまくいくようになると思います。
おそらく翻訳の機会は少なくなるでしょう。
近い将来ですが、
10年くらい
勉強して本物のようになりたいと思うのは大変だと思い
ます
[音楽]
ええと、翻訳証明書のよう
になり、突然、
重大な大衆イベントのようになります
突然コンピュータのように
基本的に何でも翻訳
できる機械学習で、あなたは残りの人生のように仕事を休んでいるようになり
ますexc 転職した職業を変えない限り
、
実際に翻訳作業を人に勧めるのは少し躊躇し
ます。また、
多くの人
が全員
ではなく、自分が何を知っているのかわからないために翻訳を始めたいと思う人もいます。
やりたいのですが、
英語を話したり教えたりしたくないことを知っているので、
おそらく翻訳はあなたが本当に
やりたいことであり、それはまったく問題あり
ませんが、もう一度
自問してみてください。 もし
私が日本にいられなかったら
、その質問への答えは
あなたが日本で何をすべきかということです。
もしそうなら
、あなたが日本にいなくても翻訳なら、日本
で翻訳をしてください。
さっき言ったけど、
初めてだったのは
ニホンゴじゃなかった
けど
、初めて起こったのは思い出せない
けど、実はこんな感じになった時だったと思う
一度ヘアカットして、
私のいとこが私に言った
ので、ええと
、それは私のいとこだったので、誰かが
私に言ったの
を覚え
ています 久しぶりに日本に来た
ので
、ヘアカットをしているときにその人に言われた時
は、あのようだったと思いますが、具体的には思い出せないのは初めてだと思い
ます。
具体的には覚えてい
ないええええええそれはあなたがいつも大丈夫だと知っ
ていることです ありがとう、
デニスええと、もう1人だけ
で、
1分ほどで行かなくてはいけません。私の妻が
すぐに戻ってくる
からです。 留学
またはただ ピッツバーグペンシルベニア
からの最初の日本訪問の挨拶のためにええと、最初の訪問のための旅行のために節約してください
ああ
、
あなたが留学しているなら、あなたは長期間日本に滞在することができますが、両方がしばしば彼ら自身のユニークな機会を提供するとは言い難いです。
短い旅行の
場合、特にアメリカ人の場合は
、就労ビザを取得できないため、3か月以上滞在することはできません。したがって、観光客として
来ただけで、より多くの自由を得ることができます。
実際に適切
な勉強をするのは難しいかもしれませんが、毎日適切に勉強
するために語学学校のように行く必要がある人がいる
ので
、両方にメリット
があります。
観光客として来て、
自分がやりたいことを決めて
、非常に短い滞在の
ようにした
後、語学学校や留学などのために戻ってくることができます。
ええと、彼は今、私がベブに住ん
でいる
ので、ヤバタンについてもう1つ質問できるかもしれません。
誰かが秋の最後の
質問をするなら、
大丈夫です
[音楽]
ええ、たぶん見てください 同じ
アニメかそうでないかを繰り返して英語のドラマのように
私はそれがおそらくモチベーションを失うことなく言葉を覚える最良の方法だと思います
何年も前から日本語を勉強してい
ましたかええと、2013年に東京のノルウェーで6ヶ月間語学学校に通いました。
2012年に日本に来
ました。 日本語を勉強するので
、
ベースは大丈夫です。
そして、iiが日本にいなかった後、
私はちょうど行ったり来たりしました。
それから4年前に
私は自分のことをするために
戻ってきました。 うまくいった 仕事中ええええ
そうアンディあなたの寄付に感謝します
[音楽]
ええと医者ええと私は
あなたが英語で何を言ったかさえ覚えていません
病院ドラマerドラマ医療
医療ドラマ多分または医療ドラマ
多分私は
オフィスオフィスを知らない
大丈夫 とにかくあなたたちが行くとき、私たち
は[音楽]を離れる前にあなたが追加したいものを何でもやり遂げなければなり
ません
でした
ずっと
チェックしてみてください。
でも、今から始めましょう。見に来てくれたみんなのおかげで、
またすぐに
会いましょう。
私のツイッターから、興味が
あれば購入できる場所をリツイートし
ましたが、皆さんのおかげで、
すぐにまた会えるようになり
ます。